marie noëlle a roulé une quinzaine de
kilomètres pour faire ses achats ici où
les vendeurs sont agriculteurs
producteurs transformateurs et même
conseiller culinaire en avant l'es13
pour bruit avec des petites recettes de
fud cru bon goût ou cuite vapeur tout
simplement posé sur une salade avec un
petit peu de nul comme elle les clients
sont ravis de cette vente directe des
agriculteurs je soutiens ce mouvement
d'hommes et de femmes qui se prennent
leur vie en main qui travaillent vivent
de leur travail et nous apporte des
produits de qualité j'ai rien contre les
produits qui viennent d'ailleurs je ne
m'étendrai pas dessus mais voilà que je
fais je fais vivre les producteurs d'ici
que c'est plus naturel c'est plus
authentique
ce sont des choses qui viennent
directement des producteurs il ya pas
mal de produits bio c'est bien présente
et c'est sympa cette sorte de super est
créée en 2011 vient tout juste de
s'agrandir pour répondre à la demande
des clients
elle est tenue par cette maraîchers
éleveurs et agriculteurs
pour eux il s'agit de proposer de bons
produits aux clients
un objectif qui juge impossible à
atteindre en grandes surfaces qui
intéresse la grande distribution
généralement c'est le prix et rien que
le prix qualité c'est pas vraiment leurs
soucis donc c'est une démarche qui est
complètement extérieure à ce qu'on
cherche à faire
donc non la grande distribution traite
pour nous parmi les produits proposés de
la viande issue de cet élevage et pour
la vente d'un body broutards cette
productrice gamme 150 à 200 euros des
bénéfices qu'elles ne pourraient même
pas envisagé avec la grande distribution
les charges ont été soit multipliée par
deux soit multipliée par trois et que
l'animal on le vend exactement le même
prix si ce n'est moi donc avec la grande
distribution aucun bénéfice
aucun bénéfice aucun rien du tout la
même chose
exactement la même chose on perd de
l'argent pour trouver les magasins de
vente directe de chaque département il
faut consulter les sites des chambres
d'agriculture à vos listes et paniers